what is the premise behind a hundred
dollar startup to the audience that
doesn't know
the premise is um
you know there's a whole model of
entrepreneurship that you're probably
familiar with from watching shark tank
or silicon valley or anything like that
that's great there's also a whole other
model of entrepreneurship that is based
on
no debt you know bootstrapping yourself
not looking for investors focused on a
passion that you have a skill that you
have
and trying to you know build a business
for yourself right so that business may
or may not scale it may or may not
become a 100 million dollar company
but you can certainly build it to a six
figure business sometimes multiple six
figures sometimes seven figure uh so you
can do more of what's important to you
and that model at the time was was
really not being
talked about much and i think that's
probably why the book did well like i
went on this tour from my first book art
of non-conformity i went to all 50
states i went to every province in
canada i was talking with my readers
like i'm hearing all these stories about
people that nobody knew about you know
and they weren't famous you know this is
like before social media was really big
and they were making a good living doing
something that
you know like they never thought of
themselves as entrepreneurs i was
actually very careful about the word
entrepreneur i didn't use it very much
in that book because a lot of people
find it you know hard to relate to you
know they think entrepreneur is what
i've seen on those tv shows or whatever
and so that whole model is like you know
you can do something right now with the
skills you have what you need to learn
is how to adapt those skills into the
new economy because you already have a
lot that you know what you need to do is
translate you know or transfer those
skills yeah
so would you consider yourself today an
entrepreneur or solopreneur
yeah that's a good question i don't um
i don't really make too much of a
distinction i'm probably much more of a
solopreneur still i mean i have a team
but it's a it's a small team i i'm not a
great manager like i don't want to have
a lot of employees so i purposely
you know keep things pretty small or
pretty lean at least um but i'm also
starting different projects and such so
i don't i guess i'm i've got
entrepreneur i suppose
yeah like your your dad and you and my
dad you guys are born seven days he's an
april 10th baby okay and and my dad let
me tell you
i i've not met an april person i didn't
get along with but uh april guys from my
experience lots of trust lots of
independence
lots of i'm gonna figure this out lots
of you can't tell them you can't do
something because that's like the kiss
of death god forbid you tell an april
baby you can't do something they're
gonna spend their entire life trying to
prove to you that they can do something
to the wiring is a different wiring do
you think
do you think like you know in um when i
interview certain people and i'm trying
to
get somebody in a position this has been
my experience
a person
who plays better in a solo game for
example a tennis player
you know a
kid like my one of my sons just loves
swimming or tennis something that's just
he controls
the success right it's his he controls
the success the other one is like it's
like
i want to be on a team i want to do this
i want to do that
you know do you think this is more like
a dna of wiring the way you are where
look i'm i'm wired this way i want to be
a solopreneur i don't like to manage
people because i don't like to be
managed i kind of know what's good for
me leave me alone i don't need to be
worth a few billion dollars i kind of
want to go do my own thing you know a
book like yours 100 startup or four hour
work week do you think there's like a
wiring where it's part of dna versus the
other guys like i want to go build
something with thousands of people
yeah yeah i i don't know if it's dna or
you know socialization or early
experiences you know that lead to that
or some combination most likely but i do
think that they you know people tend to
fall in one camp or another you know
and it's like uh you know introvert or
extrovert like there's a spectrum of
these things it's not like you're like
all the way one all the way the other so
i mean i also like to work with people
like for the event world domination
summit you know we have a team that
works on that it's very collaborative i
enjoy that
so
i think you know no matter which one you
are like you can learn some of the
skills of the other side but i do think
most people are kind of one way or the
other and i think
what you know if you figure that out
that's going to help you you know and uh
you know to play to your strengths and
figure okay what is the way that i'm
going to change the world you know
that's somewhat somewhat unique because
if i'm just trying to develop all my
skills to the same level then you know
nobody's going to care about that i'm
not really going to have an impact
that's right you're like everybody else
if you do that so the the last book that
you have um
uh uh uh which is about finding your
passion i forgot the title of it not not
side hustle what's the last book not
money tree
is called the money tree it's like
finding the fortune in your own backyard
so that's um oh sorry maybe you had
another question about that not not
money tree the one with the red the uh
uh red um
born for this born for this yeah so
about uh finding the work you were meant
to do yeah so so help me help me with
the system of that okay so i'm i'm
ambitious i'm 18 years old i'm 25 years
old i'm like dude listen chris i'm
telling you i feel like there's some
firing me i want to do something but do
i go be like this guy that guy this guy
what do i do it's so busy right now it's
so noisy right now how do i figure
myself out what's that formula yep
i think the first thing you do if you're
that you know 1925 let's say young 20s
you know guy or woman i think you um
you know you take some of the pressure
off like like there's keeping an
ambition ambition 100 the fire the fuel
but i think we put too much pressure on
people to figure out their life purpose
you know when they are 22 or 23. and i
think the way that you actually get to
that is by doing a bunch of stuff you
know i mean if you know 100
like there are people who know like this
is the thing i want to do in life and
that's great go and do that but i think
those are the minority like a very small
minority i think most of us we figure
out what our thing is by doing a bunch
of different stuff you know and by being
willing to experiment by willing willing
to start different projects and and also
to leave them behind right to be willing
to like abandon something um so i wrote
a lot in that book born for this about
um the power of giving up and the power
of quitting
because i think um something especially
in western society like this belief
about never quitting and like
persistence is the highest you know the
highest value i think that's wrong right
and most successful people have actually
quit all kinds of things you know they
have tried something and they have
walked away from it they have not been
they have not not been like unwilling to
say okay you know that was a mistake or
maybe it wasn't a mistake it was just
like that was what i was doing for now
and now i'm gonna do something different
so i think the first thing you do is you
just you try different stuff and then
you know from there there's like there's
some various assessments in the book and
it's like a model of uh joy money and
flow which i think are the three
components you know of kind of what
makes us you know happy what we find
meaningful so you want to find something
that you actually enjoy doing and look
forward to doing and like that's not
everything but that is an important part
of it so if you like this sort of short
clip from an interview i did click over
here to watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]
you